uh there are so many accounts that reach
out to people either pretending they're
me or pretending that they are
uh an assistant of mine like they'll go
like this is a
something that they'll write like here
let me look i i just can't believe that
like
here um
do i even have it or did i [ __ ] throw
it away
um
[Music]
it's a i [ __ ] don't even know if i
have it anymore but they say [ __ ] like
um
hey uh crystalia really appreciates you
so much and he just wants you to know
that and you know uh
um he's such a you're a he's so grateful
for you and
um you should write him
which is so [ __ ] weird like what is
the end game for this bot or person some
of these are profiles that look real
what's the end game they're gonna say
okay and then write me
and then what
i'm gonna ignore it
and then what
the person is doing things that don't
matter
but there's one i think this guy's
trying to get some money out of this
person
and
dude this was so great so this guy is
trying to get some i think money out of
this person i don't know what it is but
he put his account was christ delia
spelled it wrong
gonna go to hell christ delia dude and
he's writing people as me a lot of times
people will do chris dalia but like
something will be a little bit different
like with two l's or whatever so this
guy uh so this person reached out to me
and this was so [ __ ] funny dude this
person wrote this so christ dalia writes
to this person i was scrolling on my fan
page when i came across your sensible
profile your profile looks really nice
and sensible too so i decided to add you
here on my private page so we can
communicate
communicate
communicate i think i mean thanks for
being a great fan to me
dude
here's a word i never say
sensible
i don't say it it's definitely not in
the lexicon of crystalline's vocabulary
i definitely don't say it twice
i definitely don't say it twice in one
message okay
also thanks for being such a great fan
to me safari so the guy there's a bunch
of red flags right there are so many red
flags
so then this
then he sends a picture of what looks
like
me i actually i remember this picture
was when i was in australia
and it looks like i'm taking a selfie
because i was doing a video i took a
screenshot and sent it to this person
and this person wrote can you send me an
auto message saying hi to me it would
mean the world
auto message and then she says my name
is hannah as you can see on my profile
if you could say hi to me so the guy
does
and this is what he sends dude
ah
[Applause]
didn't even try
[Applause]
arabic
i comma
dude
so not chris delia
i can
hey dude you can say h
because you said hannah so say hi
not
i can
the sequel to i robot
[Laughter]
the prequel
from the makers of irobot comes
i can
[Laughter]
dude the
the most sensible movie this year
dude how could it be real how could they
go
[Laughter]
dude
so sensible
i am
dude who are these [ __ ] people what
are we trying to get
so not uh
so not gonna be me that's on my
instagram if you wanna go see it it's
[ __ ] hilarious go to my instagram
and uh dude let's play it again
i can't even
oh we gotta put on the soundboard dude i
can't
dude
these [ __ ] jerk-offs
like they think you know they think
they're gonna what are they gonna get 40
out of somebody
i cannot oh she's gonna be like what's
your cash app
[Laughter]
also
the best part was
the girl's name wasn't hannah
no [ __ ] it was not hannah
the name was not
she said her name was hannah but on the
[ __ ] her act
but her but on the profile it's not
there
it's not that it's like anastasia or
something dude doing the bare minimum
unbelievable dude i fell out when that
happened i was done i was it that was it
dude how funny is that
crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]